Identification. This is side two went on to say Sion ten. And if I did I carried that petition around in my.
For about a couple of weeks and I really wasn't.
I didn't have the courage to show it to Irene our secretary because I didn't understand what it was about.
And I didn't want to get involved in more than having these musical evenings. Raising funds for.
Then we had an executive meeting. And yes he had said to Ari on the phone.
Now tell me what are you doing about that petition. And of course what petition.
Well I gave a copy of the petition to fight.
Where Irene got onto the phone and said You bring that bloody petition in with you do you think they can you.
What could I do.
So I took the petition and I gave it to Irene and she immediately hit the ceiling in her excitement for all she said.
So it's put on the agenda. And someone says Let's have a meeting to launch it.
Yes good idea where we all chirp up you know and she said. Well.
I became very enthusiastic now when I saw the enthusiasm of the others
but not fully understanding what it was all about.
I said we're going to have a meeting which should have been in the town hall nothing but the based
and I can tell you this you know it was like my mother who would buy nothing unless it was the very best like.
If you bought a pair of shoes they had to be the finest he'd. Even if he was dragging the soles of the old one.
She bought class for. It had to be the strongest and it somehow rubbed off onto me.
And if I go doesn't matter what I buy even when I had no money.
I wouldn't buy until I got something that had some quality. So.
So I say the Town Hall of course good idea since Bert and the enthusiasm was absolutely overwhelming.
And then Erin said all right.
I could arrange once and work it and see the lord mayor talk about it and see if we can't get her to rent free.
Well it was seventy pounds I think for the rain but an eye for the town.
And we'd use most of our money up to date for printing and the like later that counted.
So are in town hall secretary might know point and for us all. But the Lord Mayor who was alderman Jensen and.
The delegation which was led by Albert Thompson secretary of the milk when union
and Albert was also on an executive at the suggestion of Perle who had known him for many years.
So he said he'd leave the delegation and introduce us to the mayor. And this was quite acceptable.
And in the delegation who was Myself and Irene and and Albert. And we have a cup of tea with them here.
And said Can I have. I had only ever seen the town hall filled for the concert. Just to have a look inside. He said.
Or you wouldn't be wanting them and I thought of for you. For you. Takes a few hundred. And I was almost offended.
We will feel it.
And he looked at me I had asked and looked Burkhead his reservations I could see that I have two thousand
and two thousand five hundred. So the mayor said before use. And asked if he would share it and he said Well.
Things got so we went back. And we started to. There was a very outstanding Australian artist who was also a printer.
And we went to Rob Rob we needed some handbills and we need some posters to advertise the town hall meeting
and you know road never charged and his work had won many prizes it was beautiful and he did big posters for us
and we litter box like crazy and work up a hand in that some of the unions came
and plastered the city telephone poles with. Posters beautiful red and black posters just beautiful.
And our public relations scintillator to the editor of The Sydney Morning Herald who was printing.
That he sent someone along to cover the meeting. It's.
Something happened and I can't remember what it was
but we were publicly accused of being raids that the rents were being given access to the town
when all of the holes were bare and it was something like that.
So there was a telephone call from the mayor secretary to Irene.
Look of very sorry that may well not be able to change your. Meeting because he'll be out of town.
And I rinsed fast and quick reply. The bastard. He's gone.
Oh they tell me to a nice like says he he's got cold bloody face has same. She was one who call a spade a spade.
That we were pleased and she was too because it made.
That we could put the Aboriginal leader Doug nickels in the charity and shared.
That very we had arranged with the member for the Sydney to launch the petition.
Well he was going to be out of town also. People were getting cold feet. So not to be beaten.
I said Halan the Member for Parkes a man of great courage and also a very cultured person right.
And a great supporter of the Australian writers and many of the organizations that had been branded by the way
and he was the Labor Member for power X. So I said to launch a petition he said Darling I would love to.
And days he lost that petition with aplomb.
If up so we were home at home and they were it was full speed of a head because I can tell you this.
I hated the thought of the mail letter saying I told you you couldn't fill it. And we packed that.
We bloody packed that. And I went up to die.
Mary and I was very Will you come and speak and she said My dear child of course I will.
And so she was in her ninety's.
They brought her there and I think her relations brought if I remember correctly
and the attendants got her in the lift to get her onto the platform. And Jessie carrying a man.
Oh it was wonderful and all a large group of people that I hired about. And if it was wonderful and they were.
They couldn't believe that I had the signator on hold for a meeting. So the others among the other speakers.
The great British villainous from Melbourne.
And we brought Harold Blair over you see we use some of the money in the kitty to bring him over from moment to speak
and to sing. So I went out to the airport and I met Harold. And I took him to a friend of mine who lived. A couple.
And I wouldn't picture was Hutchinson I took her over to the friend's place and had a rehearsal with. Harold.
And then she accompanied him on the night interest wonderful to see Joyce on the.
On the platform with Harold and so Harold really lifted that accordions out of their skins.
I didn't approve with all of what he said I read. At that time a very different man.
You know praise the Lord that the Salvation Army had saved him.
And so I would have because he probably would have been one of the Stolen Children.
But that was to beginning a very beautiful friendship with Harold and.
In the following years for many years we would meet. At the annual conference in Canberra. And it was wonderful.
I would just let him talk about whose years at the Juilliard School of Music.
How he better to continue with his training and all the discrimination he missed. Also.
We have that was the beginning of my friendship with Harold
and I think you enjoyed talking to me because nobody else wanted to hear about his years of training. And so anyhow.
So the meeting was very successful but when some of the people got cold feet. I went to. Father.
Clint the founder of the tramp ecology. And I said Listen now he's got cold feet.
And they're not going to participate and the meeting is being branded a Communist meeting.
And I'm worried that we won't get. Not only the coverage we certainly didn't get that but I'm aware.
That we will get the money to pay the rent for that all else and leave.
So rounded up some of his good clergy fellows and was a bloke by the name of Bill chiles from the mining area.
Michael and I think it was known the minus great. So he came down for the meeting.
And in the was a person from the Anglican Church by the name of father.
Frank counterattack who later became Bishop of prison. And he came among They were men Christian men with courage.
And what he did that he put the meeting started and it went with a bang
and then came the time to raise the money to pay for the rent take up a collection and Bill.
Charles got on one end of the platform.
And Frank outright got on the other end of the platform and they had a competition to see who could raise the most.
And we collected over four hundred which was. Absolutely tremendous amount of money.
So we paid the rent and we got on with propaganda. Well the fellowship flourished circulated that petition.
We got the unions to take it but the churches were very hesitant very excited about it
and as for the political parties Well I wouldn't touch it with a twenty foot rock and.
Indeed
when Jack Horner was lighter elected as secretary he was called in by John Kerry who belong to the hierarchy of the
liberal Liberal Party whose headquarters were in Rose Street in the city and this man rang.
Jack up and asked if he were.
In the office to talk to him and on the why into the fellowship office called in
and Carrick had the cheek to say to him.
Give me the names of the communists who are in the Aboriginal Australia and fellowship. Yeah.
Jack has never forgotten that and. Well there were people day and I remember a woman.
Joe and it was far shillings to do. And when we were branded she asked if she could have made me. Back.
So you know it was a terrible time but the more we were persecuted the more courageous we truly did
and it was the backing of those people that kept us go in. And then I went to great people important people Joey.
Q Second you couldn't hold back. Henry and. Joe. And I were very generous financially to the fellowship.
There were people who had it likely who had escaped the German.
The great need to help the rich people with their rights and there was nothing else going
but the fellowship at that time.
Who was dealing with the political issues that the average Chinese were confronted with being deprived of all its
rights and mentioned. And we carried on always very regularly meeting monthly.
Second or whatever it was and it grew in strength and it grew in power. And. The following year after its formation.
Jesse once again came up with the idea of forming the federal body. And she had to be an opponent for quite some time.
Well the petition was being circulated very well by the fellowship.
But there was a need for a federal body because it had to do with the federal Constitution.
So another person who felt this Jesse did was a person by the name of Dr Charles do good from South Australia who'd
given tremendous amount of time and energy to do good
and practical thing is lifting they have pretty nice out of their misery.
He was a very highly skilled surgeon and I had a lot of time with him beautiful friendship I had with him.
And he wrote to J.C. and Said look you've got to have whole body.
And we'll get the bill into the federal parliament and abolish all the state laws
and let the people function like all other human beings in the country and yes he took less. And she wouldn't drop out.
So she wrote to my friend
and her friend Shirley in the federal lived in Melbourne a scientist suggesting that felt robotic should take should
pay for. And she and I had many a chat about this. In fifty seven. I think it was in. The federal form.
In Adelaide they had a meeting in Adelaide
and that was the first meeting of what became known as the Federal Council for the advancement of every journalist
and that perceived. And we had another musical evening at Sibyl's place at Gordon. And we raised the.
After money to send our secretary he was no longer the secretary. We had a secretary. MARION.
All the dice and was still a president.
So we raised enough money to send them over to have lied to represent a fellowship at which the Federal Council for the
Advancement of a pretty loose. And the we're not overly many Aboriginal people. But there was.
And I think villainous was. A couple from South Australia. And the two.
And I have a feeling that was it the my have been more but I'm not quite sure. But Don Dunstan was there.
Yes Don was there and. It was not the Parliament hereon Oh yes a person from Western Australia.
By the name of Graydon he was a member of the Liberal Party.
But he had contact with Nicholas and he had gone into the open. With a group of other people. To visit.
A community that was said to hunger and he'd made a documentary have this show. Which we used extensively incidentally.
To publish the plight of the brutal people by the Fellowship and the Federal Council.
And I think the grain went to that first conference. Was Turnt remember I did mention her nothing.
Anything is that you went to London. I think soon after that. But anyhow. The Federal Council and.
And it had its second meeting in Melbourne and I think the third was here in Sydney
but I wouldn't say for sure whether it was the the second just now
and I had to get with the secretary of the Fellowship had poked the workers educational center.
Which was an Grambling house with big verandas invades all around the veranda a big community kitchen
and so forth for the conference. And the conference was held. I think it was over an Easter.
And I recall going down to the office to pick up a. Dance to. To drive him to the conference.
And for the child's do good. Yes he had vanished. She was probably in line and again.
At the conference got off the ground and. At that time trials do good precedent.
And it was very important people coming including off with Lamar Mark mentioned.
And he I don't think he was leader of the Labor Party but getting very close to it if you ask me.
Can I just ask you this conference was. It could have been sixty. I've got in my records.
Well they are quite a number of Aboriginal people who had come.
Not so many interstate except for the Melbourne people in the Brisbane people but the local people. And they came from.
What was known as the wooden bar. Aboriginal reserve. A man by the name of. His roots were very deep in the land.
And it was a member of the Holy Rollers of some kind of how quite sure but he was no fool and he came down.
And without invitation or he thinks someone who speaks. And I took the floor.
And he stood at the front with a dictionary in one hand and the bottle in the other hand and he said we want to L.A.
and. We want a million dollars for our land. I mean it's a big man of course and.
His request was made it was mingled with praising the Lord and that the Lord would say that we'd get the land
but it needed the council to work in the background and give it a push easy and I think you would use talking. Anyhow.
Then it came in the matter of the petition. And someone moved a motion that the petition should be taken over.
The Federal Council and it should be circulated on a national level.
And one of the speakers in that discussion happened to be a bloke name of. His student his feet and said we'd never do.
We'd never change the federal Constitution. Never. And it. We could.
But it may not be to the benefit of the Aboriginal people and took this giant to go off.
And an argument developed between. And little lane and Vic and Len said we can do it. There's nothing to stop us.
We'll go out and collect the signatures we can do it.
Anyhow the motion was put and it was carried off likes to remember that.
So the pitch Titian or circulated for the referendum and that was the beginning.
Of one of the most vigorous campaigns I would say that it ever in carried out in Australia that campaign against the
proposal to ban the Communist Party was a terrific campaign. Nobody could ever dispute that.
And I'm sure the campaign against conscription during Maurice's. Was vigorous.
Because it would have embraced a lot of middle class people who didn't want to lose this.
And had the time
and the energy to towards opposing the proposals that our referendum campaign worst horrific truly Qualls
and I thought I'd like to say here. How easy it is to be obsessed with. And observation sometimes is a bad thing.
In this case it was that it had completely taken over my life. The other person was. Kathe Walker who reverted to.
Traditional name. And have worked around the clock for the success of the referendum.
Made after me after meeting and I worked around the clock meeting after meeting after meeting.
I would put the children on the bass for school. Peter works with us in. And. Run through the house.
I've accumulated house every day engine that has at French's forest this one is luckily lucky if it gets this spitting
skittle once a week.
And I would leave the dinner ready things like that ten o'clock in the car off to do at least three meetings.
And I would comprise like the law and class.
The I picks class rotary The View clubs the churches rather than the churches had come in the church meetings the
unions who are now after all. Now that you know. I just went on. And this was happening in every state.
And that wasn't happening at every stage. Really. But by then we had television.
And I was among one of the first persons to be interviewed on television that had to do with Aboriginal rights
and that was Channel seven. Because I knew one of the presenters and that was the tried.
And many times interview me many times and so it became a national issue through television
and we were fortunate to have the right. It happened at the right time.
But the other states didn't have a person like me.
Who was who were particularly articulate and who were free to do it and had the resources to do it.
And the Federal Council was kept around Australia but there was only enough money to do that for one person
and since she had it down to a fine after was a good go drop. It was better that we put the money into just that one.
Well. I would get to make sure before three o'clock in the afternoon. Although we had a.
It really wasn't good enough for me I just had to be in the US went along with the children. Peter got in.
And then I'd spent that time between the children coming. Which would be about six o'clock. They'd have only.
Just with them. And then hands would come home and read the stories.
And sometimes they have to get in at night for a meeting. Like we had enlisted the help of municipal councils.
So there was need to go to a meeting. By invitation. And organizations like.
Multinational organizations that had been established and people from Europe. And many who had escaped.
Were very interested to see
and hear what was happening to the Indigenous Australians It was amazing the amount of interest that was taken by
people who had come from Europe.
And they were fearful that what had happened to many of their relations and friends could happen here.
Because this witch hunt. Was when the stable millions of dollars was being poured into.
These creeps of security who spied on us. Who cheated us who followed us around. And. Looking for victims.
So Australia was confronted with some serious issues at that time that had to do with the freedom of the people.
I think I should say here. I was I had so many requests to speak. And interestingly enough.
Carol and I have to go on and say that they are just pouring in. Today. Ninety seven and I can't.
Age his coat up with me then I took it in my strap.